hey leute was geht ab und jetzt
willkommen bei neuen video und zu hab
ich mir gedacht ihr kommen du hast
letzten jetzt zu zwei videos gemacht
einmal war das was jungs wirklich vorm
einschlafen machen und was mädchen
wirklich vom einschlafen machen und
diese beiden videos sind einfach heftig
bei euch angekommen da hab ich mir
gedacht ihr kommen macht daraus so
einfach sogar ab format deswegen ihr
könnt auch meine kommentare schreiben
was wollt ihr noch davon sehen ich habe
mich heute gehört wir fangen einfach mal
wieder damit an was jungs so wirklich
vom handy machen denn außer diesen punkt
da er schon im letzten video war ich
zeig euch mal kurz ein alter zehn neue
follower war dies geilmann machen wir
jungs natürlich noch so ein paar andere
sachen die wir euch mädchen nicht so
gerne zeigen außer vielleicht woanders
gucken sie sehr langweilig das kann man
sich ja denken scheint das aber ich kann
das denkt sich wahrscheinlich so jedes
mädchen hat das stimmt eigentlich gar
nicht so finde ich gut formulierte
fragen erst mal ganz locker an nach ja
wenn's euch gefällt und ihr mehr sehen
wollt lassen
auf jeden fall mit folgenden punkt das
ist eigentlich so ganz easy und zwar
kenne diese jungs die sich immer drüber
aufregen das mädchen wirklich so vieles
health machen bisher 1 nehmen was sie
dann posten ich glaube sogar ich selber
habe ich darüber auch schon mal
aufgeregt früheren videos schon mega alt
aber ich habe es halt getan obwohl jungs
meistens nicht besser sind ohne scheiß
das ist es ist sogar schlimmer bei jungs
glaube ich also was ich damit meine
sieht ungefähr so aus
das kannst du doch nicht nehmen da kaum
noch ein paar com jetzt nochmal
anspannen junge anspannung war schon
wieder 248 fotos gemacht was denn los
ja so ist das eigentlich glaube ich bei
den meisten zumindest da kann man dann
auch direkt schon die überleitung zum
nächsten punkt finden und zwar diese
bilder die ich euch gezeigt aber also
dieses jo ich bin sooo geil und so da
gibt's wirklich jungs die feiern sich
dafür wissen
das finden die richtig leistung die
denken ich bin der coolste und so obwohl
ich denke wir so es kann ja auch nicht
jeder so geil sehen wie ich und da das
fest nun spart muss man ja immer dazu
sagen
auf der einen seite gibt es nämlich
wirklich diese jungs die versuchen mit
diesen bildern halt wirklich so sich
mädchen zu klären und einfach diese
bilder ohne aufforderung an mädchen
schicken müsst ihr da will ich mich
jetzt natürlich ein bisschen
zurückhaltend das machen natürlich nicht
fehlen jungs aber das macht schon so ein
gewisser bruchteil sag ich mal okay es
kann aber auch ganz normal dazu kommen
deshalb so ein mädchen mit dem man sich
vielleicht besser versteht einen frack
schick mir doch mal sein will jetzt
keine nacktbilder so ein bild vom bauch
oder so müsst ihr aber was ich euch
sagen kann es gibt wirklich auf so ein
paar jungs das sind jetzt wieder nicht
alle so das teilte alles so ein bisschen
die machen so wirklich durchgehend ein
auf jo ich bin sooo geil und weiß ich
nicht und kriegen dann halt so diese
frage stellt die schick doch mal bild
von dem und der see und dann machen die
folgendes auf aktiven bild was mach ich
mir jetzt egal alex lex google
geiles six pack welches nehmen würden
das ist gut ja man darf mich ja nicht
sehen so stadtteil und abgeschickt geil
wie gesagt es gibt welche die machen das
so es gibt welche die machen das
vielleicht gar nicht und es gibt welche
die machen das so ich will jetzt hier
wieder nichts verallgemeinern oder so
aber wollte ich ja nur mal sagen aber
bei diesen leuten die ich euch dort
gezeigt habe bei diesen jungs da denke
ich mir so klika ich verstehe dich nicht
stell dir vor du erklärst du dir
wirklich was ist denn dann zieh dich aus
und 2 okay leute kommen wir jetzt zum
letzten punkt ich denke mir nämlich
immer so bei youtube an wie david bowie
oder biblis b
die pellets die haben so über drei
millionen abonnenten beziehungsweise
fast drei millionen abonnenten
aber wenn man mal logisch nachdenken ich
mein so im deutschsprachigen raum wie
viele leute sprechen deutsch so da ist 3
millionen wirklich schon krass große
zahl dafür dass es dann wirklich nur
mädchen sind so wie man es ja eigentlich
weiß ich nicht wenn man sagt ich gucke
bis beauty palace wird man ausgelacht
klar es gibt natürlich viele jungs aber
auch viele mädchen die diese kanäle
scheiße finden aber bei vielen jungs
sieht das auch so aus ohne scheiß man
ihr müsst mal logisch nachdenken könnte
mir nicht sagen das ist einfach komm ich
zeig euch das mal kein neues video vom
die komplette los geht's
a
und witzig finde das wirklich witzig
jetzt lebt kennt
ich könnte mir das echt manchmal
angucken ich weiß ich der einzige bin
aber das geht das video hat einfach
341.000 likes alles klar kriegen wir das
auch in kommen leute 341.000 doch locker
drin oder selbst ich gucke manchmal
babys beauty brands lasst mich doch mal
ich finde es eigentlich wirklich so
manchmal ist es ganz lustig manchmal
auch nicht aber manchmal schon leute das
war's mit dem video wenn sich gefeiert
würde ich mich echt mega dies war bei
daumen nach oben freuen wenn ihr mehr
von diesem format sehen wollt dann sagt
das mir halt einfach mit einem daumen
nach oben und schreibt auch in die
kommentare das kommt dann wahrscheinlich
am nächsten sonntag die zweite folge
oder zweite ausgabe davon was mädchen
wirklich am handy machen schreibt die
kommentare ich rede mir wieder kräftig
durchsetzbar ist das hässlich abgegangen
hier oben links jetzt weiter mit meinem
letzten video aber nie vergessen
stempelt uns nochmals ein break das ab
ging es um meine mails bzw leggins für
männer ja wenn es noch nicht gesehen
habt schaut mal vorbei und johanna und
bäm